>> A LITTLE MORE THAN A WEEK
AFTER ANNOUNCING THAT HE'S
RUNNING FOR ELECTION AGAIN,
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
TRYING TO DEFEND HIMSELF AFTER
HOSTING A HOLOCAUST DENIER AT
MAR-A-LAGO FOR DINNER.
IDENTIFIED BY THE ANTI
DEFAMATION LEAGUE AS A WHITE
SUPREMACIST WHO HAS CALLED FOR
THE MILITARY TO BE SENT INTO
BLACK NEIGHBORHOODS, AND THE
JEWS LEAVE THE COUNTRY.
IN A POST LAST NIGHT ON TRUTH
SOCIAL, TRUMP ONCE AGAIN
CLAIMED THAT HE DIDN'T KNOW WHO
FUENTES WAS, BUT THEN HE WAS
BROUGHT TO THE DINNER BY KANYE
WEST WHO HAS ALSO HAD A HISTORY
OF MAKING ANTISEMITIC REMARKS.
HE ALSO WROTE, QUOTE, I HOPE
THAT A SERIOUSLY TROUBLED MAN
WHO HAPPENS TO BE BLACK, KANYE
WEST, WHO HAD BEEN DECIMATED IN
HIS BUSINESS AND VIRTUALLY
EVERYTHING ELSE, AND WHO HAD
ALWAYS BEEN GOOD TO ME BY
ALLOWING THIS REQUEST TO A
MEETING AT MAR-A-LAGO ALONE, SO
THAT I COULD GIVE HIM VERY MUCH
NEEDED ADVICE.
HE SHARES IT WITH THREE PEOPLE,
TWO OF WHICH I DIDN'T KNOW, THE
OTHER POLITICAL PERSON WHO I
HAVEN'T SEEN IN YEARS.
I TOLD HIM DON'T RUN FOR OFFICE,
A TOTAL WASTE OF TIME, CAN WIN.
FAKE NEWS WENT CRAZY.
CNN POLITICAL ANALYST AND WHITE
HOUSE CORRESPONDENT, APRIL RYAN
AND CNN POLITICAL COMMENTATOR,
REPUBLICAN STRATEGIST ALEX
STEWART.
EVEN, I WILL START WITH YOU
FIRST.
I BELIEVE THAT WAS THE FOURTH
ATTEMPT BY TRUMP TO SAY, DON'T
BLAME ME, BUT NOT ONCE HAS HE
SAID THAT HE WAS SICKENED TO BE
IN THE PREVALENCE OF A
HOLOCAUST DENIER.
THAT'S WHAT ANY NORMAL HUMAN
BEING WOULD SAY.
>> WE TALKED JUST BEFORE THE
SEGMENT ABOUT JOHN CUTE GREEN
BLACK OF THE ANTI-DEFAMATION
LEAGUE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT HE SAID.
IT IS TOTALLY IN CHARACTER FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
HE BROUGHT UP THE EXAMPLE THAT
HE DIDN'T KNOW WHO DAVID DUKE
WAS, THAT WAS KIND OF GOING
BACK TO THIS MOMENT.
HE ALSO TALKED ABOUT KANYE WEST,
AND THE FACT THAT HE IS ALSO
EXHIBITING RACIST BEHAVIOR WITH
WHITE LIVES MATTER, AND HIS
TALK ABOUT SLAVERY.
AND THEN ALSO HIS MISGUIDED
MINDSET, IF YOU WILL, ON WHAT
HAPPENED TO GEORGE FLOYD.
DONALD TRUMP WAS IN COMPANY
THAT DOES NOT BODE WELL FOR HIS
ATTEMPTS TO INDIA THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY OR THE BLACK
COMMUNITY.
EVEN THE COMMUNITY AT LARGE,
BECAUSE THIS IS VIEWED AS
RACIST, AND SYSTEMATIC, AND
MORE.
>> AND WE'RE TALKING TO
JONATHAN FROM THE
ANTI-DEFAMATION LEAGUE IN OUR
5:00 HOUR, SO STAY TUNED FOR
THAT.
ALICE, PART OF THE PROBLEM WITH
TRUMP'S EXPLANATION IS --
AS RIDICULOUS AS IT IS, WE'VE
HEARD A VERSION OF THIS BEFORE,
IT MULTIPLE TIMES.
LET'S WATCH.
>> JUST SO YOU UNDERSTAND, I
DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT DAVID
DUKE.
I DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
WHAT YOU'RE EVEN TALKING ABOUT
WITH WHITE SUPREMACY.
YOU ALSO HAD PEOPLE THAT WERE
VERY FINE PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO CALL THEM,
GIVE ME A NAME?
>> WHITE SUPREMACISTS.
>> ALICE, WHAT DID YOU THINK
WHEN YOU HEARD ABOUT THIS?
WHY ARE WE NOT SEEING A
STAMPEDE OF REPUBLICAN LEADERS
COMING FORWARD TO ABSOLUTELY
DENOUNCE THIS AND SAY THAT
DONALD TRUMP IS NO LONGER A
MEMBER OF THIS PARTY.
WE'RE JUST NOT SEEING ANYTHING
LIKE THAT, WHY NOT?
>> I WOULD EXPECT TO SEE MORE
THAT, WE HAD CASES HUTCHINSON
ON THE STATE OF THE NEW THIS
MORNING, AND HE TALKED ABOUT
THIS HE SAID WHEN YOU MEET WITH
PEOPLE, YOU EMPOWER THEM.
IT'S WRONG TO HAVE PEOPLE LIKE
THIS IN YOUR PRESENCE, IN YOUR
HOME BASICALLY.
TO BE QUITE HONEST, JIM, YOU'RE
KNOWN AS THE FRIEND YOU KEEP.
IF THEY BRING AN ANTISEMITE, A
RACIST, TO YOUR HOME, IT SAYS
JUST A BUNCH OF IT YOU AS IT
DOES ABOUT THEM.
THE FACT THAT DONALD TRUMP
ALLOW THIS PERSON DOWN TO
MAR-A-LAGO SAYS AN AWFUL LOT
ABOUT HIM.
WHEN YOU BRING SOMEBODY TO THE
TABLE, YOU GIVE THEM A VOICE IN
CONVERSATION, AND NOW THIS
HOLOCAUST IN IRAN HAS A BIG
PLATFORM AND A VOICE FOR HIS
HATRED.
THAT IS WRONG.
HERE'S THE POLITICAL
IMPLICATION OF THIS, JIM, YOU
KNOW HOW THIS WORKS.
ANYBODY THAT IS SERIOUSLY
LOOKING AT BEING A REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATE IN 2024, YOU'RE UP IN
OHIO, YOU UP IN IOWA, NEW
HAMPSHIRE, IT HAVING DINNERS IN
DES MOINES, NOT WITH RACIST AND
ANTISEMITE'S IN THE COUNTRY
CLUB IN FLORIDA.
THIS WILL HAVE TREMENDOUS
POLITICAL IMPLICATIONS FOR HIM,
THERE ARE OTHER OPTIONS TO
THINK ABOUT.
>> AND APRIL, PRESIDENT BIDEN
IN NANTUCKET THIS WEEKEND WAS
ASKED ABOUT THIS, AND UNITE
BOTH KNOW COVERING THE WHITE
HOUSE, SOMETIMES THE PRESIDENT
HERE'S A QUESTION AND DOES NOT
WANT TO ANSWER, IT DOES NOT
NEED TO ANSWER, BUT PRESIDENT
BIDEN MADE THIS COMMENT.
LET'S WATCH.
>> MISTER PRESIDENT!
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT DONALD
TRUMP HAVING DINNER WITH A
WHITE NATIONALIST?
>> YOU KNOW WHAT TO HEAR WHAT I
THINK.
>> WHAT DID YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT
THOSE WORDS STILL SPEAK
VOLUMES.
YOU WANT TO KNOW WHAT I THINK?
THIS CURRENT PRESIDENT BECAME A
CANDIDATE FOR THE OVAL OFFICE
BECAUSE OF WHAT HAPPENED IN
CHARLOTTESVILLE, AND THAT CLOTH
YOU JUST PLAYED, THERE ARE FIVE
PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES AT THE END
OF THE DAY, YOU HAVE A
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
WHO REALIZED THAT THE MAN WHO
IS THE IMPETUS FOR HIM TO RUN
AGAIN IS DOING IT ALL OVER
AGAIN.
THIS COULD BE HIS OPPONENT.
HE'S PROBABLY BEING VERY
STRATEGIC, IF I'M PUTTING OUT
MY UNDERSTANDING CAP OF WHAT A
PRESIDENT AS HE'S PROBABLY
BEING VERY STRATEGIC IN THIS
MOMENT AS TO WHEN TO TALK, AND
HOW TO TALK ABOUT ON THE TRUMP.
BUT ALSO, ONE THING THAT WE'RE
FORGETTING IN THIS CONVERSATION,
I WONDER WHAT JARED KUSHNER,
HIS SON-IN-LAW IS SAYING ABOUT
THIS MOMENT.
THAT'S ONE PERSON I WANT TO
HEAR ABOUT AS WELL, IN THIS
MOMENT.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
LET'S MOVE ON TO SOMETHING ELSE
BESIDES YOU KNOW WHO.
TWITTER'S NEW OWNER, ELON MUSK
SAID ON FRIDAY, AND THIS GOES
TO WHAT YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT A
FEW MOMENTS AGO.
HE WOULD SUPPORT GOVERNOR RON
DESANTIS, AND WOULD RUN FOR
PRESIDENT IN 2024.
HE MADE THE COMMENT THIS PART
OF A LENGTH RIGHT ABOUT WHY HE
IS DECIDING TO GIVE TRUMP HIS
TWITTER ACCOUNT BACK.
HE'S OBVIOUSLY A BILLIONAIRE
THAT NOW OWNS THIS PLATFORM.
WHAT IMPACT DO YOU THINK THAT
HAS, BUT EVEN MUSK IS HEARING
THIS FROM OTHER FOLKS IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
THERE IS A LOT OF MOVEMENT
TOWARDS RON DESANTIS, WHICH IS
KIND OF A HOLE THERE --
A PLACE HOLDER FOR ANYONE BY
TRUMP.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
SEEING A LOT MORE FOR
REPUBLICANS AND ELON MUSK, AND
PEOPLE WITH BIG PLATFORMS AND
VOICES, IS THAT WE DO NEED TO
TURN THE PAGE.
ANOTHER THING THAT HE SAID WAS
THAT HE WOULD SUPPORT SOMEBODY
MORE CENTRIST AND SENSIBLE.
HE HAS EXPRESSED HIS CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION,
SO I THINK IT'S POSITIVE TO
HAVE SOMEBODY WITH A PLATFORM
LIKE ELON MUSK TO ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE, AND SPECIFICALLY
REPUBLICANS, LET'S FIND
SOMEBODY A LOT MORE SENSE TO
PULL THAN THIS.
I ENCOURAGE TRUMP TO LISTEN TO
THOSE VOICES.
HERE'S MY MESSAGE TO TRUMP'S
BASE.
IF YOU REALLY WANT TO HELP
TRUMP'S LEGACY, YOU NEED TO
LOCK ARMS AND LINE UP BEHIND
SOMEBODY ELSE.
SOMEBODY THAT'S MORE CENTRIST,
SOMEBODY THAT IS A RATIONAL
REPUBLICAN, A COMMON SENSE
CONSERVATIVE.
SOMEBODY THEY CAN WIN A GENERAL
ELECTION, BECAUSE I TELL YOU,
SOMEBODY THAT IS AS EXTREME AS
DONALD TRUMP AND AN ELECTION
DENIER CANNOT WIN A NATIONAL
ELECTION IN THE FUTURE.
WE LEARNED THAT FROM THIS PAST
MIDTERM ELECTION.
>> HE KEEPS LOSING.
HE WAS A LOSER IN 2018, THE
MIDTERMS THERE, AND OF COURSE
2022.
APRIL, MUSK ALSO SAID THAT HE
WAS FINE WITH TRUMP NOT USING
HIS RESTORED ACCOUNT.
WE HAVE TO REMEMBER, APRIL, WHY
TRUMP'S ACCOUNT WAS SHUT DOWN,
BECAUSE OF TRUMP INCITING AN
INSURRECTION ON JANUARY 6TH.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF WHAT ELON
MUSK IS DOING?
>> WORDS MATTER, AND ELON MUSK
HAS ALIGNED HIMSELF BY ALLOWING
DONALD TRUMP TO HACK HIS
TWITTER ACCOUNT BACK, WITH
SOMEBODY WHO IS VERY
CONTROVERSIAL AS THE
INVESTIGATION CONTINUES, AND
WHAT HAPPENED A JANUARY 6TH AND
OTHER ISSUES.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, HE OWNS
TWEETED LIKE HE OWNS TESLA.
IT'S HIS ENTITY, AND IT'S ALSO
OTHER'S DECISION TO STAY IN
LINE.
THERE IS BEEN A CHANGE WITH
TWITTER.